[Music]
everybody and welcome back to full vara
it's been over five months since the
last episode came out and I really want
to get back into this thing so here's to
hopefully this finally being one of the
last episodes since I've been trying to
finish this series for about half a year
and the endless procrastination doesn't
really lead to anything so here's
hopefully to change and to finishing
this thing sometime soon now one of the
reasons why it took me so long to get to
this point and finally release another
episode has everything to do with the
topic for this episode you might have
noticed that the title is a bit of a
triple entendre if you will it actually
has nothing to do with the saying of
bottoms up as in drinking or anything
like that it's just the fact that the
bottom of the island is up for you know
the topic for this video that's the
thing that I'll be working on in this
video but also you know this is the
bottom of a flying island so it's
somewhere up in the sky I was way too
proud of that title but never mind it
definitely it is the thing that I
struggled with the most though and it's
really the reason why it took me so long
to finally get to this point because I
wanted to do the bottom of this island
but ever since starting this this whole
series I had no idea what to actually do
with it
I was just sort of procrastinating on
finally getting to it and thinking of a
solution of how to make the bottom look
decent enough and fitting enough with
the rest of the island to not you know
ruin the whole shape and be this very
big blob of ugliness at the bottom of
what's otherwise something that I'm
pretty proud of but at the same time I
didn't want to make it too extravagant
to actually draw your eye away from the
castle itself which should be the focus
of the series in the end you know so in
the end I got this idea to just put some
blanks on it and just leave it for
another episode and that was about half
a year ago so yeah that wasn't entirely
fruitful now what I decided to do
over here after just some experimenting
and figuring out that it actually looks
pretty good is to just put an endless
heap of machinery at the bottom of the
island a bunch of all sorts of pipes and
catwalks and scaffolding and whatever
kind of stuff could be running like all
of the machinery that sort of poking out
of the island in a sort of haphazard way
is basically how I'm gonna be doing the
bottom of this it is an exciting
it isn't exactly going to be like the
bottom of a ship I guess where it's
gonna be you know all tights and have
this neat little border at the end some
sort of thing to keep everything looking
clean it's gonna be the exact opposite
of that it's just gonna be a bunch of
machinery sticking out and all kinds of
pipes and stuff they're not gonna be any
gears because that sort of felt very
pointless I'm not entirely sure what
would go through these pipes but I
imagine it's no gonna be all of the
water and oil and whatever else this
island needs to keep running in the sort
of way that you know the idea behind
this is also that kind of like a real
car so it just sort of grew over time
and as a result it's a sort of modular
weirdly put together mess of tangled
towers and machinery and everything and
I felt that having everything stick out
at the bottom of this sort of fits that
whole idea there's also gonna be some
other stuff so there will be some
catwalks to care for whatever kind of
machinery there needs to be over here
there's gonna be some things that
supports the things that are happening
on the top of the islands so some things
that are gonna support the tracks that
run around the island of the coaster and
you know all kinds of other things if
you steam machines poking out some roots
of trees I guess at some points whatever
ever works you know this thing doesn't
entirely make sense oh I did actually
put a very obvious steam machine with
gears over there but yeah some things
don't really make sense at all and I
just sort of slept on to it which in
this case I figured I could just go for
this instead of keeping it clean so for
once I'm just putting random stuff
to make it look steampunky in the end
though I am pretty happy about it
because this is not so much about the
way it looks when you know you look
close up to the island and you sort of
look at the details of this but it's
it's more to give the whole island a
different sort of appearance because the
problem that I had for a while
is that without all of this stuff around
it the bottom of the island seemed very
thin very flimsy and like it wouldn't
really match the top of the island
whereas if I if I balked it up a little
bit if I added some terraforming to make
it a bit more round it almost becomes
too round and it just becomes a big fat
sort of blob so this whole structure
around it so that makes it it's really
hard to put it but it sort of connected
a little bit more to the air around it
it makes it sort of disappear it makes
it sort of oh transition into the sky if
that makes any sense so there's not
really a point where the island starts
and it's not really a point where the
onion stops it just sort of becomes more
and more dense toward the middle where
everything is it basically doesn't
really make any sense but it looks
pretty cool especially actually from
this point where I'm adding the lamps
and stuff because it's just talking off
with these lamps to light up which is
pretty cool and you know it might not
look that good when it's lit up like
this and over here from this close-up
but if you sort of zoom out from the
island and especially you know if the
lighting is good then the whole bottom
part of the island is sort of obscured
and you can see all of these dark wires
and pipes and little lights everywhere
and then the top of the island is
actually lit up so you've got this
really nice contrast between the sort of
nice Victorian sort of very nicely
detailed top of the island versus the
messy and industrial bottom which sort
of grows everywhere so yeah I thought it
was pretty interesting I'm not entirely
sure this is you know to be honest
always been my project where I'm the
least certain of the things that I'm
doing normally you know I built some
things and it's always fun to look back
at it and doing the building it's fun to
look back at it
but with this project I I've always been
a little bit disappointed myself and
I've never been a huge benefit so that's
one of the reasons why I have such a
hard time actually getting the
motivation to work on this and I kind of
feel the same about this thing as well
it's just a whole weird concept and it
only know it only starts making sense
when everything is finished then you can
see the whole picture as opposed to when
you're just building a coaster or a park
on the ground and you always at least
have something that you know routes it
in realism you've always got the the
whole land around it that makes it look
a little bit better but in this case
it's just completely nothing up in the
sky and it still always a completely
stupid idea in any case what I also
decided to do to just make it look a
little bit more interesting and make it
also a little bit more realistic am I
really saying realistic air to make it
seem to make more sense that there would
actually be all kinds of floors down
here I added a few of these little
points where it sort of juts out and
you've got some windows and you've got
some doors that lead you to the outside
here just to make it seem a little bit
more believable that there will actually
be some sorts of floors and anything
that you can do down there I've no idea
what's gonna be in there it just looks
pretty cool I should also say that with
the way that I'm building this I am
going a little bit against my own
principles in you know the building of
evaru as a whole since I'm copying
around a lot of stuff which works fair
enough I guess I'm not a big fan of
copying around stuff because I prefer
everything to be kind of unique but in
this case it's just a weird jumble of
wires and pipes so it's hardly
recognizable that some of them are
copying around but usually it's
something that I don't really like to do
and you'll notice that a lot of stuff
around the island is very unique there
are just a few things that are copied
here in there and sort of motifs but
most of know every part of the island is
unique because of that very idea that
it's sort of added over time and it's
not built in one go so it makes
everything look a little bit more unique
and it makes every schulz of the
building that you get
a sort of unique looking shots with the
details looking slightly different than
in another shot for example and with the
the bottom part of this I am sort of
going against that it's just that I
wanted to finish this in one episode and
not spend too much time on it so in a
case like this I think it's pretty handy
to just save time and save some sort of
template that you can start copying
around although still I think it's
pretty important when you start doing
stuff like that and you copy stuff
around just to save time you always add
some things to it here and there and
remove some things from it here and
there and during the whole process I
also changed the whole bunch of you know
those sort of templates pipes and wires
that are always copying around I changed
that a little bit every now and then
just to make sure that it looks a little
bit unique all over the bottom of the
island it was a pretty fun process in
the sense that it's pretty mindless
don't really have to think about it that
much just keep adding random stuff where
there's empty space left and just grab
all kinds of weird objects and just
stick them to the bottom of the island
because to be honest it just kind of
works like that so it was something
where I can't even remember what I was
doing at the time but I think I was
actually in a voice call during much of
this which for me personally is
something that I actually rarely do most
of the time when I work on projects I
just want to be alone just sort of shut
myself off completely get some sort of
inspiration pictures just for ideas
whenever I'm stuck and get some music to
sort of get me in the mood at some
points I was actually listening to you
know steam powered giraffe just while
listening to Valera just to get into
that steampunk mood but I think in this
case you know it's just some some of the
stuff is just really boring so just put
up like any kind of voice call or do
something else in the meantime because
especially this adding the planks over
here it's just time consuming and for me
personally the most important thing to
get right is the sort of image that you
have in your head of how you want
something to look like and for that I
think you totally need a lot of
concentration so especially when I'm
doing park layouts or coaster layouts or
trying to figure out how to assemble
buildings and how to make a composition
of stuff I always want to be alone and
like really look at it myself really
well and concentrate on that whereas if
you're just adding detail stuff like
that it just feels a lot more mindless
and it's just a bit more of a sort of
numbing process oh and also also
something that I did for a little bit
here is I had to remove a lot of stuff
since there were just some parts where I
added those template pipes without
really much of a care for where they
would end up just so that I could have a
few of them and then I just removed the
rest that are in positions that aren't
very handy which is still more
time-saving than building a few pipes in
just places where you want them
sometimes it's easier to just put a
whole bunch of stuff there have it all
copied around and then remove the parts
that don't really fit in now over here I
I wanted to change the whole composition
of the island a little bit I still think
it lacks a few towers yes I want to add
more towers to this and also it could be
a little bit more bulky on this side so
just to give it a bit more book in terms
of building size I put this little
bridge here of arches it doesn't really
make any sense
architectural II yeah that was that was
not an intended plan but it's something
that's pretty handy I guess in trying to
make the appearance of the hill of the
whole building a little bit more bulky
because that was just this huge gap in
the middle here which I wasn't too much
of a fan of I just need to figure out
where and how I'm gonna finish the rest
of the few towers that I still want to
build speaking of which I do think there
is only about one episode left on this
whole series since at least that's what
I'm trying to do I know I said that four
episodes already but I'm trying to do
that since there isn't too much left to
do it's just a little bit more of
bulking up the building adding some
extra towers and supporting some of the
pieces that are still floating around
like the two curves at the end of the
coaster here and finally a little bit of
interiors I'm not sure how much I'm
gonna do of that's because the problem
with the interiors here is obviously
that there's no
terraforming to actually make them like
well-lit so the lighting is always gonna
be awkward but I think the the new
haunted DLC pieces will come in pretty
handy so we'll see what's gonna happen
there and yeah I think that is just
about it after doing all of that
the coaster should be more or less
finished so starting from the next
episode
I should hopefully be able to record the
final video and get that out sometime
soon as well also I'm gonna have to work
with the new sort of logo that you saw
at the beginning of the video you might
have noticed that I didn't use the old
quote-unquote logo it wasn't entirely a
logo I just sort of quickly through that
together as well but I have to use some
new stuff for some of my series since I
didn't bring all of my projects to Japan
which is kind of stupid I didn't even
bring all of the fonts that I had used
to Japan so I don't know half the fonts
that I used for my stuff in the past so
yeah I I just need to go with the whole
new design on this project also as you
might have noticed I didn't say this in
the last episode of Jaeger horn but I'm
using a new mic not a Ty Lee new I'm
just using a different mic because I can
bring my whole blue Yeti into Japan
that's just way ridiculous those things
are way too big so I'm using a samsung
go mic which is pretty cool for how
small it is but it's it's not a it's not
a great setup in fact my setup over here
is actually really horrible because I'm
putting this thing on a gorilla pod on
my desk in front of my laptop but I
don't have a pop filter so there's a
sock over that thing however I'm doing
my laundry today so the sock that I put
over my microphone is one that I used
already so the whole [ __ ] time while
doing this commentary I've been smelling
my own old dirty sock so yeah it's it's
it's all worth the sacrifice I'm all
doing this for you guys don't worry
about it it's a hard life being a
youtuber sometimes just kidding it's
it's still really awesome it's totally
worth talking into dirty sock for in any
case some of the last stuff that I'm
doing here is a quick support of the
coaster supports over here which are
probably still not making any sense
physically but yeah I figured I did my
best I know in some of the in one of the
first episodes my
actually been like the second or so I
put those supports there but didn't
bother to support the supports just kind
of those one of those things where I
couldn't figure out how to do it so I
just left it for my future self to
figure out which is actually what we do
in real life a lot but it never really
ends up working out very well so I had
to quickly figure out something to
really support this thing but I did that
only after finishing the bottom of the
island so now I'm also stuck with all of
this stuff on the bottom of the island
and it doesn't entirely match up so
there are there are some struggles over
here but overall I'm pretty happy with
how it ended up in the end it's not too
bad looks like it's decently supported
you know at least we're on a steampunk
floating island so what does it really
matter in any case that's it for this
episode so thank you guys for watching
and I hope to see you guys in the next
and hopefully last video of the series
bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]